hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I am just checking in on you
just checking in on you
seeing how your week's going
my week's going good I'm on vacation
vacation for what you [__] liberal
piece of [__] when was the last time you
picked up a hammer and [__] swung it
y'all ain't working out there you don't
strike on strike from wood playing
Make-Believe
y'all come out here South Carolina
experience little [__] reality
can you spell that Mr [__] Hollywood
Rider
so sick of you [__] liberals
bellyaching I'm out here trying to
listen to Travis Tritt
um
taking a [__] little bit of a break
I'm still doing some stand-up men
because that's the deal you can't you
can only take a break from stand up for
so long and then it starts dipping it's
like doing cardio
right you're on that elliptical every
[__] day
you know you're blowing through you're
getting five thousand fifty five fifty
five hundred [__] steps in and a half
hour
like it's nothing
staring down the soccer mom next to you
what you got woman
um
why don't you go back to your Thigh
Master where you belong
I don't know why I've adopted this
southern accent but it's [__] fun
I don't know a lot but I know enough you
know what I mean you know what I'm
saying
I don't need to know all the information
to know what's going on
not to say that southern people are dumb
it's just fun to act like that in that
accent I mean you could do it where I'm
from
dude I got Street smarts
you know what I'm saying just [__]
all these [__] suits in the carpeted
area walking around with their [__]
you know oh I got a position
you know
they [__] you don't have an office
you have a cubicle all right when the
walls don't touch the ceilings that's
not an office all right
you like one of those dogs with a
[__] lampshade around your neck
except it's a [__] office
um
you know never in my life have I been
able to read a spreadsheet and I don't
have any desire
to [__] learn
I did take an accounted class
and like most classes it started off
well
got a B on the first thing I would do
well in introductions and then I start
getting
overwhelmed by information and then it
just kind of all falls it all falls to
the Wayside
what is it whatever the [__] that means
I don't even know if I'm saying that
right there's an expression to look up
the Wayside how do you spell way
is that like whey powder
is it w-e-i-g-h
it all falls to the Wayside let's let's
look this up shall we
it all
Falls
to
the way side is that even an expression
well it's all one word
it all falls to the Wayside and instead
for it all falls to the Wayside
wait
okay what is fall to the Wayside if
someone Falls by the wayside they fail
to finish an activity and if something
Falls by the wayside people stop doing
it making it a using it so why does one
company wow
origin we got to go origin here
hang on one second sorry
God damn it you [__] curious
[__]
oh God from the parable of the sour told
by Jesus
or Jesus and record it to the New
Testament of the Bible the term
appearing in Matthew 13 colon 4 Mark
Mark
14.4 [__] Luke
oh he's dragging ass 8.5
the parable is the story of a farmer who
sows seeds
and some Fall by the wayside and it was
trodden down and the fowls of the air
devoured it
well thank you for explaining that
um
by the way somebody sent me this [__]
clip
of pink at Fenway Park
and it had to be the sickest thing I've
ever seen
you know she's always had like the
trapeze stuff flying around the
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon stuff
right
she's it she's like in the Outfield
then all of a sudden she just starts
doing backflips over the whole crowd
across the whole stadium on this wire
just and they had her lit up like
Tinkerbell it looked like anyway and she
just [__]
I don't know how many she did look she
did like [__] 20 of them
across a Major League Baseball Park and
then she landed on this little thing
like Superman like wave to everybody and
then they brought her along the upper
deck and she was like running acting
like she was running in air along the
[__] Upper Deck
and then it goes back to where she
started and she's still running in the
air and at one point she just has like
one leg up and one leg down like Landing
like Superman and this [__] thing she
landed on couldn't have been more than
like like two feet across a little
circle and she landed right on it
it was like the sickest thing I think
I've ever seen in a concert
I just can't imagine being on drugs
way at the back of the stadium and
you're just sitting there going like
Jesus Christ these [__] seats suck
I mean that might as well be Martha
Stewart down and all she's just like
that's [__] coming at you
look wait a minute
I hope she warned people if hey anybody
on psychedelics just to let you know
this is real
okay it's all done with wires you know
it's
super safe all right just letting
everybody know before I freak you out
that's what was killing me because it's
the greatest visual thing I think I've
ever seen I watched it like a hundred
times
like I don't even know how does she
count how did they time it like how does
she know like she's doing the back flips
um
I don't who the [__] doesn't who the
hell would do that
all the [__] that's happened in concerts
[__] lighting things falling down on
people paralyzing me you do that
that's like astronaut level balls but
anyways I was just kept thinking about
if like nobody knew that technology
existed but somehow they had it back in
the 80s when I was going to concerts and
I was just thinking like and you had no
idea that was coming like what the crowd
would have just stampeded
out of the stadium thinking you were
like a [__] witch or something
you know if you went to go see Queen and
Freddie Mercury is up there I paid my
price I paid my dude
Stadium
this guy's a [__] witch let's get out
of here man
laughs
anyway
shout out to Pinker and anybody who saw
that I can't imagine if you're up there
and all of a sudden even just for that
moment even though your seats suck right
not the back flip part
but when she runs by like she's on this
[__] invisible unit like like she's
on a horse
just came flying by I mean that right
there makes it like work that worth the
trip I think it's a really smart thing
you know some remember back in the day I
saw the Rolling Stones
and uh
what was it Sullivan Stadium
and I was way up in the upper deck
and uh you know Mick was like the size
of my [__] thumb
and he never [__] flipped through the
crowd
he was just up there sashaying in his
[__] loose clothes
he's always wearing like Silk or
something raw it can't have me clay
who's touching me body
and move around a lot yeah
don't know if you've seen in a band
Rolling Stones been around [__] 60
years it's the worst English accent ever
uh hey Keith can you cool it
um
anyway I was [__] Blown Away by that
I don't know who the hell came up with
that [__]
we had Tommy Lee going upside down
in his drum kit but even then they
showed it in the music video so you you
they Motley Crue was nice enough to give
you the heads up that it was coming
because they knew that their crowd was
going to be on drugs
um anybody was at that Fenway show like
tripping on mushrooms or whatever
and had no idea that that maybe you were
a casual fan of Pink I'm coming
I'm coming at you like you know you know
like the hits
right you don't know the deeper Cuts
deep pink right
so you just [__] go with a friend of
yours you know and you're like well you
know all right at least I can do some
drugs
anybody did anybody go to that show and
have no [__] idea that that pink was
gonna be in seven seconds right next to
your [__] seat
[Laughter]
you'll be [__] hilarious if everybody
rips her off and then that just becomes
the standard thing like you have to have
that
at a concert and then all these [__]
old guys from My Generation all the
thing I got to do what and all of a
sudden you know
[__] old ass David Coverdale
it is still in that and he's [__] got
to do like [__] back flips all right
Bill we get it whatever I was blown away
by I think it's amazing
um
but I also you know I could not take
myself out of The Fan Experience there
come on
like you gotta [__] warn me
if you're gonna do she must have been
flying around
before that and that had to be the
finishing move like I don't know how the
[__] you top that
um
you start dropping money
[Music]
in a gesture of generosity goes horribly
wrong at the pig concert
I was looking down at people were
tearing at one another and I was like no
this money's supposed to set you free
I'd like to apologize to anyone who was
trampled for the doublooms that I
dropped while doing 27 backflips from
one side of Kaminsky Park to another man
it's just [__] that is incredible
suppose to me I just stand there
doing the old [__] jokes so I'm on
vacation here man
and I've been riding this back every
[__] day
uh renting a buck finally downloaded an
app
you're like Phil you're on vacation why
are you still yawning why are you still
tired oh cause I have a three-year-old
son who comes in every morning at
[__] 6 58 whether you like it or not
hi Jada
loud as hell
I want egg sandwich
that egg sandwich data
and I gotta be like
what's up son you gotta you gotta you
gotta be patient you gotta be patient
and then he just drops his voice down he
just goes egg sandwich
I wanna egg sandwich tada
egg sandwich
[Laughter]
then I start laughing and then he gives
me that killer smile oh my God it's over
my heart melts the next thing you know
I'm up I'm up and I'm making a [__]
egg sandwich
he can finally hold the sandwich close
you know it's the best was when he
couldn't and the exit fall out and he
would just go oh no
oh no Dada oh no
[Laughter]
I would just play along going oh no jeez
geez get those eggs you gotta squeeze it
gotta squeeze up the [__] toast
together
um
anyway
I've been eating like a [__] Champ
eating like a champ
smoothies salads
you know trying to learn how to do
splits sorry I had to add something even
more feminine in there
um
um anyway uh what else was I doing I
caught a little bit of coffee last night
um I did go out to dinner
and I ordered really well
but then I saw the dessert menu
and you know me hey hey I don't need to
tell you guys about me right I mean
believe me you'll know what I'm thinking
I used to love Colin Quinn used to do
bits about guys like that I [__]
loved it
hey and you know me no I don't know you
you [__] narcissist
um anyway
uh
yeah I say I don't eat dessert it's been
[__] fantastic
because everywhere you know it's the
summertime
and I'm going around and wearing you
know
it's touristy place and
everybody's [__] eating ice cream I
don't know what it is I think ice
cream's the thing to get this year which
I gotta be honest with you I don't know
why you get ice cream on a hot day why
the [__] you would go for dairy
you would never go like oh my God it's
[__] hot out somebody give me a glass
of milk and these [__] people are
chowing the thing and I say this every
summer there's nothing funnier than
watching a grown man eat an ice cream
cone
It's the funniest
homophobia has gotten to the point that
is a straight man if you have a banana
you have to be like breaking pieces off
of it you can't just eat the banana like
the way a chimp does because everybody
says it looks like you're going down on
a [__] dick right that's the latest
homophobia
I don't know how the ice cream has
gotten away with it it's a guy sitting
there going down this looking like you
know the whole [__] thing is just
like
it's like
you know the manliest of manly guy and
then all of a sudden he's just given a
sloppy ice cold [__] as he's walking
down the street I [__] die laughing
every time I watch it it's the funniest
[__] [__]
[Laughter]
um
anyway enjoy your summer everybody
that's just even just in general there's
just something funny about a guy
standing there holding an ice cream
that's even better when he's waiting for
his wife just standing there holding the
ice cream
like all he needs is like a balloon tied
around his wrist
um oh bill can we just enjoy you know
one of the last Summers before the
Oceans Rise and swallow up probably 12
of the 50 states
um
I cannot [__] oh so anyway so last
night we're at the restaurant
and for like a year and a half I've been
craving butterscotch pudding
like I don't know what got knocked loose
in my brain but back in the day
you know
my mother used to buy those Swiss Miss
instant pudding things that were just
100 fructose
corn syrup whatever the [__] it was all
trans fat I mean
if I have a drop of a [__] heart
attack it's because of those [__]
things way back in the day
and um
but whatever I was like craving
one of those
I wasn't creamy craving a gourmet
you know butterscotch [__] thing but
I wanted the [__] Swiss Miss and uh
last night I go to this restaurant
my lovely wife my mother-in-law
and uh
we had a great meal and I looked at the
dessert menu and they had a [__]
butterscotch pudding
with some sort of whiskey something and
I was like I would have gotta put this
booze in it and he is like it burns off
Burns out of there all right
you're not a chef I'll take that for a
[__] answer right
so
um
I ordered the thing but all three of us
split it I had like five bites of it and
uh
it was very good
but it was afterward where I was just
like you know what it that didn't
scratch the itch I wanted to go back
and child sense memory I wanted like
because the one I had last night was
[__]
was amazing
but I wanted the [__] white trash one
you know
the one somebody comes knocking on your
[__] trailer door
you come walking over
you gotta have to [__] dessert you
mustache
can I help you
[Laughter]
that's one of my favorite things people
say when you're trespassing
can I help you
it's so [__] like
like non-confrontational but conference
what passive aggressive I guess would be
but I also like how all of a sudden
you start talking like you work at a
Macy's
is there anything I can help you with
you know keys to my car
um
tell you where my watch is in my in the
house
may I help you excuse me
are you lost
excuse me is there a problem
these are the expressions of people that
have not had a fight in 30 years and
don't want to have another one that's
how they they
um hello
notice none of those [__] sayings
were ever in a Sylvester Stallone
Schwarzenegger Steven Seagal Jason
Statham movie they never go uh
you know
is everything okay
well I guess they could get away
excuse me are you lost I'm trying to do
Schwarzenegger
what's a good Schwarzenegger I don't
give a [__] bill
have you guys watched the documentary
The Schwarzenegger documentary yet
that's what keep I keep hearing that
voice still here in my head
you got this picture in your mind of
what you want your body to look like and
you will it you will your body
whatever the hell he said that just
stuck
you will it
to look like that
so
I want to look like that that old dad
that maybe used to do hard drugs because
that's one of the things that they don't
talk about
about hard drugs is when you do hard
drugs
younger in your life for whatever reason
you're just like skinny for your whole
life
you know
look at all these rock stars all the
ones that had like the big heroin
problems
they come out you know it's this weird
sort of like
it's like this heroin dad bod that they
come out with you know where you can see
their rib cage where their chest where
their pecs should be you know and then
they just have like this little [__]
this little pot belly
[Laughter]
um
I am fascinated I do this thing with
Dean Del Rey where we try to find the
most the most accessorized
rock stars
and you just try to see like where where
it went off the rails
um
I mean it just gets crazy all right so
you got the [__] leather on leather
outfit you got the tattoos then you go
with the eyeliner
right and then you gotta have like
like [__] 40 bracelets
like 12 earrings you just look at him
you know like a [__] headband I love
wearing a bandana and then you put a hat
on top of the bandana and then there's a
bandana tied around the brim of you
[__] at you just want to look at them
like dude how long does it take you to
get [__] dressed and undressed in the
morning
I mean just to [__] sound
you know some chicks dating this guy hey
hang on a second I gotta get ready for
bed and he just goes in there and it
sounds like somebody dropped like a
[__]
like a box of nails
it's just him getting taking all of his
[__] he'd even take them all off
now they all link together some of these
[__] people
bandana a hat on top of the bandana
bandana around the brim
and then they got like some sort of
[__] glasses 40 [__] earrings nose
ring that connects to something like
they're [__] I don't know what
something else it's like we get it
we get it you make money
[__] playing music
I kind of feel like it's it's like as
they go around the world people keep
giving them gifts and they just keep
putting it on themselves
Laura I made this jacket for you oh
thanks mate and then they [__] put it
on and then they get another jacket and
then they cut the sleeves off of one
all right it's a jacket on top of a
jacket with a windbreaker
and then a vest and an Overcoat
sorry
I think that idea was as long as it
takes to get [__] dressed as a rock
star
that's why it's not Malcolm Young had it
down
guy would come out black t-shirt white
T-shirt whatever blue jeans
underwear socks sneakers done
maybe just go out there and play and
that was [__] it
the man did not have a stylus yet came
up with his own style
I did wonder how many of those suits
Angus brought out on the road
I mean he has to have I mean it's like
workout clothes with that guy
comes off stage it's like he's coming
out of the ocean I mean there's no
[__] way
they just hang that thing up wet and let
it dry and then he [__] does it I bet
early on in his career they did oh Jesus
now there's a question nobody asked
Angus
hey seven nights into your tour on the
high voltage tour how nasty was that
[__] Schoolboy outfit
um
all right I don't have any [__] reads
I don't have any reads did you guys see
that thing not to get into politics here
this is I I am watching the I like I
have no hope okay so I'm just watching
just to see if my suspicions
are true
so everybody claims on the left and the
right that they like a straight shooter
and all of that type of stuff and
somebody that's gonna tell it like it is
right
so
um I S somebody sent me this thing
that RFK Jr
told this whole story about how this
Corporation with this one guy at the
head of it
um put all these independent Pig Farmers
out of business you know they just had
more money and they had a more efficient
way of killing pigs and they were able
to slaughter like 30 pigs 30 000 pigs a
day and butcher them and because they
did they drove the price of like pork
all the way down to like
I don't know 25 cents or something
which caused all these other independent
Farmers to go bankrupt
and then
if you wanted to keep being a pig farmer
you then had to sign a contract with
this corporation that put you out of
business
and they support the corporation
supplied you with the piglets with the
food
you know you had to do exactly what they
said they basically became serfs like
the feudal system on their own land they
took over it basically I don't know 80
percent of pig farms in this country and
then in the end you know what they did
they sold it to China
foreign
so these are the kinds of stories that
you say this is wrong and this really
messes with America
right
you watch what they do to that guy
you watch how they [__]
try to tear him down and all of the
because all of these [__] politicians
know this shit's happening
and you know this isn't new information
but you know they can't be Pro senators
and congressmen cannot be prosecuted for
I guess insider trading
they're privy to all of this stuff and
because they can't
these companies on Wall Street send them
information
to basically give them the hookup so
they'll make a bunch of [__] money
and then essentially look the other way
when these corporations are doing evil
[__]
so all of these [__] [__] where
they go like hey he's a public servant
he isn't they're serving themselves
so whenever a guy like this comes along
you know
Robert Kennedy
junior or Bernie Sanders and even Trump
in a way
even though Trump was was sort of the
corporate evil [__] guy
like how he he made himself out to be
like this Robin Hood guy when it's just
like dude you like
the amount of money that you've cost the
average Joe with all these bankruptcies
it's like you just don't declare
bankruptcy and they wipe away the debt
they got to get the money back like we
have to pay for that and he stood up
there I took advantage of the uh the
bankruptcy laws and his own [__]
people are applauding him yay we paid
your tab
and none of us are a member at your golf
course
um
I just find it fascinating watching the
liberal Democratic party what they did
to Bernie Sanders these last two
elections where he won the popular vote
and they were just like now we're still
giving you a company man and they gave
us Hillary and [__] you know
Joe Biden I mean
I don't know we'll see what's going to
happen I I don't have any faith that
like
you know I'm waiting for a politician to
start talking about this stuff because I
don't understand what we're doing we're
completely letting the
country go to hell
and then if you bring it up people ah
he's a [__] Socialist Communist Fang
the gas will be nine million dollars a
gallon if this guy gets it and then the
guy just goes away every [__] time so
you watch
um and it'll be done by the left
um
which is disappointing because all I
want all I want
for the next president I just want
somebody sane that gives a [__] about
people
is that asking too much
or at least doesn't have dementia all
right anyway we'll see what happens
though everybody
um this is all butterscotch Bill signing
off have a wonderful uh beginning of
August don't get upset that it's August
enjoy August
all right
it's still this summer all right see you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
August 3rd
2015. what's going on
how are you can you believe it's already
August 3rd
where is the summer going
no need to fret everyone
because now that we are in the Golden
Age of global warming you know right
before all the bad [__] happens the
great thing is is summer goes right
through to like October at this point so
there's still time to get your beach
body ladies
and gentlemen
um you know what really helps with you
you ever just get depressed at how
quickly life is going by how quickly
time is going by you know what really
helps that is if you're working towards
something
I swear to God and I try to get all
[__] goofy here and self-help I'm
actually excited for August to end to
get right through this month because I
know where I'm going to be because I
I've been I've been working oh I've been
working out
today
I stepped on the scale and my goal was
to get go for 180 to 177 drop my three
pounds for the [__] week I go to the
gym every day
it's just become puppy life
and you know what I'll be a fatty wow
you go to the gym every day you [__]
whoa
um
I got on I got on the scale Babble when
I got out of bed
um no I got it on the scale this morning
and uh I weighed in
at 176
.4 or Point foa as some people say in
Massachusetts or basically the New
England area 176.4
six ounces to spare
pretty psyched about that
what I did this week was I just kept
eating the exact same way that I've been
eating
which is is perfect as I know how to eat
you know there's only so much you can
read about nutrition
you know about good carbohydrate what a
good fats bad fats good cholesterol bad
cholesterol [__]
glycerin whatever [__] it is I just a
glucose and all that [__] I just look I
just shut up all right with your your
words you know I I those [__] words
don't excite me
they don't make me go oh oh what's the
next sentence going to read I got to
figure out how to get excited about
reading about nutrition
you know I just can't I cannot get into
reading about nuts and berries you know
what I mean there's no car chase there's
no titties
there's no classic lines no no shiny
suits there's nothing what is it there
for me
you know it's like sitting through with
some [__] movie
you know you didn't want to see but you
[__] up in your relationship so you're
trying to repair it see like all right
all right I'll [__] uh
oh yeah let's go see this movie what is
what is it called what is it called
seven suppers in September
what the [__] I'm thinking about
dinner dates Divine whatever the [__]
it's gonna be anyways
but I I switched up the cardio this week
I went to the gym and I skipped rope a
couple of times so it was a different
kind of cardio so my body's still like
hey whoa whoa what the [__] going on
you know because I overheard somebody
you say You're supposed to confuse your
body every like or three to six weeks so
I did that it's working for me
it's working for me oh boy oh boy I know
I'm psyched that I'm losing weight but
uh
this is the time because I'm recording
this on Sunday night and uh it's about I
don't know seven eight o'clock I don't
know what the [__] time it is and uh
this is the time of night where I
usually uh crack open a cold one and I'm
not
I'm 28 days in 29 when you hear this
and uh you know so now I'm not craving
alcohol I don't give a [__] about it I
mean give a [__] but like I'm not like
you know I'm used to my new lifestyle
you know
this is it
just wide awake
all [__] brain cells
straight in line all counted for
ah Jesus Christ I'm bored shitless
[__] bored shitless but I am working
towards a few things I took my first uh
um auto rotation uh advanced auto
rotation class and I [__] loved it
and I felt like I got like 30 percent
better
Adam in one lesson and I'm just gonna
keep taking those [__] things until I
can simulate
a uh engine failure and land it like
essentially in a parking spot and once I
do that then I'm gonna feel like all
right now I feel comfortable to fly
around take some passengers and that
type of [__] that's what you do you
don't get your license and then go well
I passed the [__] test let me just
fly around and hope nothing happens
that's not what you do
you keep going you keep learning
keep trying
um
[__] 28 days in 72 days 72 minus 28
that's 52 minus eight 44 44 days to go
I'm rapidly approaching the halfway
point which is 36 Days
was 28 7 35 [__] Phil's hoping next week
I was gonna be at the halfway point
who's getting who people I'm gonna come
off I'm going to drop about 20 pounds
and I am going to come off this [__]
this stretch of no booze and I'm going
to put on at least 30 pounds just a
booze weight forget about all the dumb
food choices I'm going to make when I'm
hammered
um
oh Jesus so anyways 176.4 there you go
so all I gotta do is lose 2.4 this week
I don't give a [__] I just gotta plow
through this [__] week
you know because then I'll be down to
174 and then it gets exciting right then
you start getting into the low 170s and
that's basically you know that's where
you know in my business I could go out
and get a head shot maybe a book a
Cheerios commercial that's an exciting
way to be in you know what I mean
now you can sit there and laugh those
toasted always commercials they [__]
pay I did one a long time ago I think
it's up on YouTube
uh if you search for it
said search old uh Billy red face
toasted hose
no I'm kidding I never did one of those
but I wasn't a honeycomb commercial when
I was just a kid
honeycomb's big yeah yeah yeah it's not
small no I wasn't in that [__] either
um anyways let's get on with the podcast
here
so uh
that's the deal trying to get in shape
you know what I mean because I'm not a
young fella anymore
and uh if anything tells me that is when
[__] you know
Heroes of mine from when I was a kid die
in their sleep
[__] devastating news of Rowdy Roddy
Piper passing away this week man
I couldn't believe he was [__] 61.
I couldn't believe it was that old and I
also was thinking like that's 14 years
away for me and for in 14 years you can
die in your sleep like that can happen
and everybody's okay with that you know
like oh you know I'm not okay with it I
mean they missed the guy and [__] but
anyways so
rest in peace Rowdy Roddy Piper thank
you for all the [__] laughs Piper's
Pit man that was the best
just when they think they know the
answers I change the questions I got to
meet him a couple of times when I was
down The Comedy Store and I had a chance
to hang out with them one time and I
didn't because he was that big a deal
for me and I didn't want to know him too
well because he was such a big [__]
deal that's when that I'm telling you
before the Rock and Stone Cold Steve
Austin which was definitely a golden age
and I think the rock is the best guy
ever on the mic other than [__] Ric
Flair that's what I my own personal
opinion whatever but uh before the
Golden Age of the Rock Stone Cold Steve
Austin mankind
um
um oh who's the guy
oh what the [__] was he called I just
know what the Rock used to call him used
to call him the red you know what
ah what was his name
I forget anyways in the 80s
was it Kane something like that I can't
[__] remember
um
Rowdy Roddy Piper Sergeant Slaughter
Mr Wonderful
Jimmy Superfly snooker
I I [__] I used to watch all of that
[__] Larry zabisco Tony guria Ted
DiBiase
Greg The Hammer Valentine Ivan putsky
Pat Patterson
who else
the end of Bruno San Martino and now oh
there was a redheaded fella there we had
the belt what the [__] was his name uh
Bob Backlund
um
Hulk Hogan Andre the Giant
the Iron Sheik
George The Animal Steele
the [__] Moon dogs
Mr Fuji and Mr Saito the med of the wild
Samoans Captain Lou Albano Freddie
blassie the grand wizard of wrestling I
used to watch that [__] every [__]
week I loved it and one of the biggest
Parts when [__] Rowdy Roddy Piper
came on the scene it was like who the
[__] is this guy
came out that celt it from day one was
talking she was one of those guys she
showed up and he was a star it seemed
like it was just overnight he was so
good you couldn't remember wrestling
without a man and I can't believe that
man 61 years old he looked great too
when I saw him [__] look great
it's terrible you know I'm getting to
that age where that gets terrifying like
how old was he what the [__]
so uh anyways
um
yes
yes it may start to make me feel old so
I feel good that I'm actually working
towards some [__] so oh Billy [__] 20
Hobbies here so I'm working on those
Auto rotations and I actually started
taking drum lessons again because I'm
sick of [__] flailing around the
kitten uh
you know
I was always I always admired guys that
had that that [__] Flawless technique
and I think seeing Keith Carlock when he
played with uh
Steely Dan and just watching the
obviously no matter how much technique I
have I'm never gonna play like that guy
but just watching
um him just effortlessly go around the
kit
and the sticks are doing the work he's
just guiding it with his hand it's just
[__] it's really some drum geek [__]
but it's [__] unreal and having said
that does anybody know who who was Jim
Croce's drummer does anybody have any of
the idea I'm trying to figure out who
played on that working at the Car Wash
Blues
which is really you know it's kind of a
corny [__] song who's kidding who but
the drums on it are this [__]
I love the drums on that [__] song
and I finally figured out that little
[__] uh
I'll play a little something for you
this is a little [__] press roll that
the guy does in the beginning
and I'll say where the hell is it come
on oh here we go
there it is coming up right now
right here
oh I [__] love that
and two three and and one
I've been sitting in my [__] just like a
[__] rain man trying to figure that
thing out and I started taking lessons
and uh
my teacher helped me out with this [__]
I'm psyched so I suck at it but I know I
know physically how to do it so I just
got you just sit there and you do it a
million times who knows maybe I'll bust
that song out at the uh The Comedy Jam
Little Jim Croce
God damn it that guy's got some
depressing songs
huh
New York's not my home
and I learned a lot of lessons and they
were not the nice kind of all the shitty
things about [__] sleeping uh in a
doorway getting mugged having to call
his parents
that New York's not my home I just
started singing that
don't you know that I gotta get out of
here
so alone
don't you know that I got
I got out of here cause New York's not
my home thank God I never knew that song
existed when I first moved to New York
and was eating my balls at the old
Boston Comedy Club I would have gone
home crying
that was that early 70s [__] they were
not about bringing people up they were
just like nope sit in it sit in that
depression
you know he's got a couple
he's got I got a name
you know lots of pine trees lining no
Winding Road
I Got a Name
I got a name except the song doesn't
make any sense
like the singing bird and the croaking
toad I got a name that neither one of
those animals has really as a name
unless it's a pet other than that it's
just called what it is
it'd be like if your name was human
being right
you know maybe we should just sit back
and enjoy this song I don't [__] know
but I just you know
and I carry it with me like my daddy did
and even then it gets sad but I'm living
the dream that he couldn't give what did
that mean he drank away his paycheck
every week it was just [__] good Lord
guys putting out number one songs and
he's all he's all [__] sad
reminds me of the the Seattle guy there
right with the page boy haircut he was a
saddy too I had all these great [__]
albums he didn't like it here
um anyways what am I doing what am I
talking about here
there's something I wanted to talk about
oh so my wife for whatever [__]
reason absolutely loves that show uh
that American Greed
and um
she watches like three of those episodes
every [__] night before we go to bed
and I and I always end up falling asleep
because it's the same [__] story over
and over again
you know it's the same thing the guy
starts up for [__] business he
dressed in a part he's faking it till
you make it he gets a bunch of investors
he hands out fake spreadsheets and he
got these [__] innocent people just
going like you know oh yeah I saw I saw
the recharge and I was getting 30
percent and I was like this sounds like
a good deal of me right
and then they always go you know there's
always some really bad metaphor
they invested in an ice cream chain but
this wasn't the flavor they were looking
for when we returned
glass in the ice cream
wow
that [__] song
of American Greed
I'll tell you nobody's gonna end up on
[__] American great is that [__] who
shot that lion everybody's talking about
this dentist that went over and
illegally poached this lion that was
friendly with people I love that [__] is
it friendly with people until what it
bites somebody's [__] head off
[__] unreal you know what I mean
everybody's [__] Salient gas the pit
bulls you shoot a [__] lion
everybody's like oh
I'm not saying it was a bad line I'm not
saying the guy shouldn't have done it I
think everybody's missing the [__]
story here
all right speaking of American Greed
this guy paid 50 Grand
all right
that's just for the [__] that's not even
for his flight
to go over there and kill this [__]
lion
all right
not trying to stir anything up here but
how the [__] can a dentist afford to
drop 50 Grand
to fly to Africa to shoot a [__] lion
illegally
just think of all how expensive the
shoes he had to buy that he had to sneak
around and there had to be some sort of
ninja wear [__] I'm gonna shoot a a a
a protected lion where that he had on
right
I dropped 50 Grand on that and now he's
gone underground they go over his house
he's got a mansion
right and all they're talking about is
this [__] line and I'm I'm watching
an episode of American Greed
how
many teeth are you feeling
this guy's pulling teeth he's I'm
telling you right now I used to work in
a dental office right and I there was
some good dentist just like cops there's
some good cops there's some bad cops and
I'm not talking about interrogation
talking about brandishing a weapon uh no
I'm talking about [__] people pulling
teeth that didn't need to be pulled
[__] doing root feeling fillings on
teeth that did not need to be [__]
drilled into because they bought a car
beyond their own [__] needs or
whatever their their financial
responsibility
all right I think this guy should be
[__] taken back there just for the
simple fact
just for the simple fact that that he uh
he went to another country and did that
what do we got over here
does the MGM still have a lion what if
he what if somebody from Zimbabwe came
over here what about in the MGM lion
right
right as they were recording that you're
watching an MGM film they [__] please
turn the air conditioner back on
yeah the lovely knee everybody she came
in this is a studio man Dave Letterman
had a cold I'm having a cold he lasted
[__] 30 years on television I want to
do 30 years of podcasting
huh
well what's good is the air conditioning
if you're gonna [__] turn it off
listen I'm talking about that dentist
that went out went over to Zimbabwe
you got to go grab a mic from the uh
from the closet there
I I you know no one wants to listen this
let me just hit pause here ah [__] it I
never hit pause
um
do you know that story Nia
this dentist from Minnesota
he's a b you know he likes
he's one of those big game Hunters you
know what I mean he's one of those
[__] guys I'm gonna shoot something
that people think is scary and they can
be like God I killed that [__] you know
like it went up and he [__] put it in
a chokehold
it's like you didn't you went over and
you shot it the fact that you can go you
can walk up
and kill an armed man
a human being with a gun you could
[__] kill you could you could do it
even if he knew you were coming you have
a gun he has a gun you could do that so
now you're going up to a lion the thing
doesn't have a gun so I mean how [__]
difficult is that actually they shot it
with a crossbow but the only reason why
they shot it with a crossbow is because
they were trying to disguise doesn't he
have he's gone big game hunting before
right like he's done that a lot
well here's the thing I thought I saw
some weirdly alarmist headline being
like you know he's like a serial killer
of animals and it's like the way they
were putting it was like you know this
is what he does all the time I don't
know he's one of those guys he doesn't
seem like he kills to eat it yeah yeah
it's just for sport yeah he's one of
those guys to be like yeah you ever hear
of an alligator a [__] shot one in
the head it was he put it up in his
study or something like that he's one of
those guys he's one of those guys what
about him he's fled right like he uh he
went over to Zimbabwe he brought like a
crossbow and he [__] went into some
like Wildlife Sanctuary allegedly this
lion was friendly with people I love
that [__] so that's all the lion Cecil
or whatever it was it was it's yeah it's
friendly until it isn't until one day
you do something that reminds us it you
know of something from its childhood and
it [__] bites your head off but it's
what it's supposed to do it's a line
yeah you kill [__] yeah of course so he
went in and he [__] killed it
decapitated it skinned the [__] thing
yeah he wants the head yeah first of all
how do you get the head back
I don't know I don't want to know that
you got to go gym bag
you're gonna drain it out they probably
do it there like oh no you know what he
did he probably like Taxidermy well he
probably like takes the [__] just
this the skin from the head
you bring that back and then you just
you have somebody like make a uh like a
lion skull and then you put it over
there because no one was gonna know if
the skull isn't in there
right this is the kind of [__] this is
like no idea wait let me ask you this
now because you're into American Greed
this guy's a dentist he paid 50 Grand to
do that now he's gone underground
they're going by his house he has a
mansion this guy's a dentist he's a
mansion he's going all these expensive
[__] uh you know going around killing
all these how does a dentist have all
that [__] money is he like a
hoity-toity fancy dentist that like
doesn't take any insurance if it's all
like self-pay and it's I worked in a
dental office nobody was going on a
safari even to just look at him forget
about two just on a safari how much
money that is forget about you're going
to go over there and then sneak back
later kill a lion butcher the [__]
thing and sneak it back
yeah I don't know he sounds very sketchy
though
[Music]
that's American Greed that's all doing
the theme to American Greed later
yeah do your best Stacy Keach impression
well give me a scenario what it's always
the same scenario same thing it's like a
Ponzi scheme and he throws lavish
parties and he buys Ferraris and BMWs
yeah I told him Ferrari Mike dude how
many times how many times how many times
has ludicrous gonna show up in the
background of one of those this has
oddly shown up on two episodes of
American Greed greedy white people love
Ludacris
I [__] can't get enough of them I
don't know it's really weird though yeah
he came up twice
it's [__] hilarious not that he does
business with these people but he's like
he knows the people that did business
with one person being profiled it's like
that it's like a private party you know
when they like that you're so rich you
can have ludicrous wrap in your living
room
I love that show
yeah
that [__] that Missy Elliott song
used to draw me up again
remember that [__] song pass that
Dutch yeah they'd be like way down
nobody pay attention nobody gave me [__]
remember that one that was the only good
part of the song was when he came on
that's the best part
I loved it it was inspirational no one
believed in him and he said [__] this he
made his own goddamn tape and then he
would sell him out of the back of the
car and then he was crushing it yeah
yeah that's true he's going to be on
Empire next season I didn't like that I
didn't like the part where he started
buying the Gators it's just like no no
no no no real estate
oh I'm sure he has tons of Real Estate
that's a guy he's singing about the guy
he's rapping about
ludicrous Oh I thought you were talking
about Ludacris how soon before Ludacris
is on American Greed at some point he's
got to come clean like he's gonna be on
Empire I just told you next season he's
going to be on Empire well I'll tell you
right now if he shows up on a third
the third episode of American Greed
somebody's got to be like Ludacris like
yeah who's he who is he hanging out with
yeah I don't get it
I don't know look how white I am I don't
know any white guy on that show that's
pretty interesting huh I'm sure you do
actually they just haven't shown up yet
I'm sure you know or have somehow
tangibly been involved with some like
crazy corporate American Greed type dude
but it's just so funny I used to do gigs
I bet one of those guys went down of
course
yeah no but not if not if you donate to
a [__]
a campaign no but you're like a white
guy working in Show Business Like
There's at some point you came across
somebody that did some American Greed
type [__] like that's just how it goes
no I don't think so
I don't think they go to the funny bones
in the improvs
I think when you sell out stadiums like
him
of videos theaters like venues promoters
the last one we watched this guy ended
up he throws a party in like
Indianapolis and he has ice sculptures
cut into Playboy of Indiana yeah cut
into like [__] dollar signs yeah and
then he stood on his balcony with
hundred dollar bills and this none of
the money was his and just [__] did
the he made it rain he made it rain
and like just what I love about those
what I find them so fascinating about
them is just just that living in the
moment and thinking like how long do you
think you're gonna [__] get away with
this and then they do but then what then
it's always kind of funny just the dumb
[__] they buy but then once they
actually start showing the people that
lost it's always like you know he was a
farmer he grew food for the country
he never sold out to corporate farmers
he had 170 Grand he gave it all to
Ferrari Mike yeah
that's true they have like 100 he had a
nice watch he was well spoken I thought
he was a nice person yeah it's always
like 120 170 000 that's like their
entire life savings and then they take
it and then and they go all right and
they still get the fake [__]
spreadsheets and they immediately walk
out the door and they go buy a watch
with that like you realize just like
just go spend it on themselves yeah
those Yachts that six million dollar
yacht we saw surprise that was only six
million I know I didn't feel like it was
really all that for six million dollars
like the deck of the core and everything
it just we're talking about basic to me
what I thought that that thing would be
like 40 million bucks that thing oh it
had seven bedrooms with their own
bathroom on a boat no I know wait is all
that [__] go MIA that's expensive hey
can you turn it can you turn the [__]
AC back on please are you really that
hot I was freezing my ass off when I
came in I know you weren't some old
ladies sweater on that's are you hot oh
you just want it on because Letterman
had it on are you actually yeah no it's
fine I'm dying in here really okay I'm
white you know it's all that hot air
oh touche
white people like the [__] coldness
we do
we're pasty yeah we're white like the
snow near
all right
I wanted you to go well I think there
was a question that somebody wanted to
[__] ask you
where is it where is it did you talk
about our Beautiful Day by the pool
today no that was so nice can we talk
about [__] UFC [__] yes let's talk
about 34 seconds
of pure domination
by Ronda Rousey
I didn't that was the [__] I didn't know
what that girl had said about her father
that was the first like when you said
that
last night that was the first time I had
heard that
oh yeah that girl or like so one of our
friends said that they came over last
night that she said something about her
dead father
and she don't do that why would you do
that Rhonda already hates you just by
virtue of the fact that you guys are
gonna fight why would you throw fuel on
that fire by talking about her family
like she already just feels like if I
step into the ring with you I wanna like
kill you hurt everyone that like loves
you that's that's what her mindset is so
I don't understand why she thought that
was a good idea strategically trying to
do some like psychological warfare when
she knocked her out and Rogan said she
went down like she got hit by a sniper
immediately that that goes in his
all-time [__] quotes everybody in
that living room bursts it out laughing
she looked like she got shot she did she
fell over in that weird posture where
like you sort of end up falling on your
neck yeah bent over at the waist and
your ass up in the air like with your on
your knees just terrible yeah like
somehow your legs stay awake longer than
your upper body and you just go in it's
look I respect anybody who goes into
that [__] thing but like why the [__]
would you go in and
nah say all that [__] not a good idea so
what she learned she learned Rhonda I
usually discipline I usually root for an
underdog especially when someone's so
dominant you just want to see a fight or
whatever but once you said all that [__]
about her dad I was like all right yeah
you have to uh you have to I was
actually upset that she didn't get to be
here longer
yeah because she deserves another like
34 seconds again I felt like the third
the third punch she had a look on her
face like oh [__] and I thought I I
think I said this is already over I feel
like that need too kind of like caught
her off guard I think she got a little
winded when she got her that like left
knee to the body she was kind of like
cool not sure nothing I would have
started crying yeah once I got my win
back why did you do that
um well I don't know I can't find the
question I don't see one here
listen to your podcast years that's the
Russia one [__] Ronda Rousey just
dumb it just it like it's the same thing
every time now
it's just to say like she's probably not
gonna fight for another couple years
there's no other woman that's lined up
ready to fight Ronda Rousey is there
like I I don't know my friend said she
does have another he thinks maybe she'll
fight again in another six months or so
but like I I don't know who out there
can take her
I I don't know I don't give a [__] just
stick somebody else in front of him
[__] amazing to watch I don't give a
[__] to people good you're gonna do the
pay-per-view it's only 30 something
seconds it's like you're watching a
legend
you're watching a [__] she's already
a legend at this point and you're
watching her I don't think she's in her
prime she's through the arm bar thing
all the time and now she came in
no I'm by I really knocked the [__] up
yeah she did she just knocked her
[__] block off yeah that's great
enjoyable totally [__] enjoyed it
yeah so anyways uh let's let me I can't
find the [__] questionnaire I like
better when I bring you on in the end
because then we ride it out because I
always feel weird like having you swing
by like we don't live together
you know what I mean okay
okay fine then we'll hit
we'll do you're leaving yes
I was going to talk about that Paleo
Diet
those people trying to just tell us the
whole thing do you want to do Paleo
I think it's [__] hilarious why
that's pretty much it well I mean that
makes sense but here this [__] thing
here oh by the way so do you do you hope
that the United States extradites this
dentist back to Zimbabwe do you feel
like he should do 10 years in prison in
a hardcore prison uh he's gonna get that
it's gonna get a little he's going to
get butt raped I think I think he should
be fined probably a lot like a lot no
[__] that I think he should be taken
back at some point you got to put a
value on animals lives I agree so what
you're saying he should go to jail I
think he should I don't think he should
go to the hardcore one right I think
that he should go to the jail be in
protective custody and through his 10
years he should have to fix everybody's
teeth
I think for free he should work in an
animal sanctuary like cleaning up all
like the [__] and everything you can't
have that it's like having a pedophile
work at a kindergarten eventually he's
gonna [__] kill somebody
there's not some law in place about him
going and killing that animal because it
shouldn't there already be something no
there is but he left the country he left
the country he's back here so now he's
got to get the United States to send one
of their own now the United States we're
not going to send the guy because that's
one of our guys he's got the barcode in
the back of his neck and he's not making
us any [__] money if he's by us I
mean the Illuminati guys you know what I
mean he's not paying any [__] uh
income tax or any of that type of [__]
he's not walking around you know saying
what he's supposed to be saying because
he got it out of his TV you need that
zombie you need that guy he's a big game
hunter that guy he's going to be on the
side of those I got to be honest with
you I totally respect hunting I think
it's the [__] I love animals too but I
think if you go out and you hunt and
then you you do it for food or whatever
or you're doing it to learn how to do it
I respect that go shoot a [__] deer
there's a zillion of them they're like
mosquitoes but like to go out there and
and uh you know shoot a lion a leopard
did you have these beautiful [__]
animals with this yeah dude believe me
if there was a bunch of [__] if it
was herds of lions running along the
Prairies I mean that's what we would
have on the fourth of July but what not
we [__] killed all of them I think
there's really something uh
like uh
I don't what this guy does I don't lump
all Hunters into did he go out on his
own was he like this road no he hired
these people I was gonna say he hired
people right so he had people who knew
the terrain and those guys are busting
those guys are are going to trial and
they're staring at 10 years oh they are
oh yeah and being a bottom I was gonna
say I know he paid somebody like an
exorbitant amount of money in order to
do that he didn't just go out there on
his own yeah it was incredibly stupid of
the people who lived there and this
[__] I don't know he must have had
the size of that duffel bag that he must
have put the [__] head in it's just I
love how you're obsessed with the whole
how does the head travel from Zimbabwe
to a man what do you do
[Laughter]
put it up his ass like those drug meals
oh you have to fill out those little
cards we traveled internationally it's
like are you gonna are you bringing any
fruit or any like Wildlife or anything
like plants or [__] I got an elephant's
head in my duffel bag
do you mind if I look in your bag sir uh
yes I do do you have any liquids in
there
no it's all been drained and he's so
sharp object you can't do any of that
but the [__] with the
I actually think there's something
[__] wrong with you if you have to go
around and kill the most
deadliest animals to human beings like
walking around doing that [__] I feel
like that was an old school like Teddy
Roosevelt yeah I'm an insecure guy and
like you say that it isn't it during
this like foreign land like isn't that
the whole thing it's like you sort of
take over the people and the
neighborhoods and like the countries and
then like kill all their Wildlife isn't
it all about like
I'm the big man and I can just sort of
yeah I don't control nature as well as
man I don't know what it's about but I
can tell the only thing I'll give him
props was is he used the crossbow
you know that's but of course you know
it had the [__] laser pointer and
[__] but like I I just
I think America has bigger problems than
rich people shooting Lions meaning what
they shouldn't they shouldn't pay
attention to this I I just think there's
more important things to Rally behind I
don't really care I mean I I don't give
a [__] about a lie I give a [__] about
this I yeah of course I care about lions
but I care about human beings more who
do you care more about lions or a Snoop
Lion Snoop Lion
yeah I care more about Snoop Lion
than an actual lion yeah
two animal names yeah it's extra Snoopy
in life
no I mean I just like I said I don't
think it's right that he's going over
there and I think my aunt is completely
wrong but I think that and I think it
should be turned over given everything
that's going on right now I I don't I
can't bring myself to what's going on
what's going on just in terms of like
climate in terms of like politically
racially all that stuff all the stuff I
was telling you how I'm afraid for my
brother to drive political and racial
climate yeah I care more about that than
uh a lion in Zimbabwe I do that's just
how it goes but I love lions
why are you looking at me like that it's
not that confusing no I know just
fascinated by what's interesting I was
sitting there looking like I think
animals are more important than people
at this point I feel like that's the way
a lot of people's reactions they get so
upset over animals
where people place their ire when it
comes to rights I just sometimes feel
like the rights of animals seem to be
worth more than the rights of some
people and I think that's [__] up
I don't
no you care more about lions you care
more about a lion than snoops I like
animals I care more about Snoop Lion
than a lion I got nothing against Snoop
those are bad
it's funny it's funny though no I just
think that uh that there's too many of
us and I would definitely rather be in a
room full of animals I think than a room
full of people no I wouldn't I don't
live with animals I don't and I like
people there's just too many of us and
the fact that we don't think we're
animals is bizarre to me because we
behave way worse than they do
way worse yeah that's true yeah it was
completely you know
Bears don't change rivers and straighten
them out and [__] poison them and
build nuclear [__] animals we're
animals right torture [__] Kill [__]
Kill [__] to kill [__] we lie and cheat
and [__] well [__] I'm an animal
we're [__] awful but in the same
there's too many of us if I had to
choose between that dentist guy and a
lion because you said would I choose a
lion or Snoop Lion and I said Snoop Lion
but if I had to choose between a lion
and that dentist guy I would choose the
lion racist all right Nia thank you for
being here what if Snoop Lion killed the
lion
that would be hard but what if he just
sort of he just saw in that lazy
laid-back [__] voice Justified
CD in any situation
kill a lion because he's not gonna he's
not gonna [__] with him you know what he
wouldn't no because we don't do that I
mean you don't do that we don't do that
you guys like to do that whole racing
with animals thing I mean listen people
watch these white these shows about like
Wilderness and survival and like naked
and afraid it's like I mean there was
one black dude that I saw in the
commercial but like for the most part
and you can always find one person
that's going to be an exception of the
rule but it's like I don't know why
white people feel like they need to
constant like [__] with animals or like
be out in nature naked like we've
evolved classed why are you doing it I
don't get it
oh really yeah we don't have a cause
we're not being oppressed it's just so
you need nothing to give you that sort
of wave in Russia 16 hours a day that's
yeah that's why we jump around and flip
around on skateboards and [__] we're
bored oh Jesus that's so terrible I'm
not saying it's terrible
which is Bored generally speaking white
people remembers I showed you that of a
certain income yeah we're bored where
there's a white guy like standing on
like a cliff like an I don't know like a
Grand Canyon or someplace really [__]
scary and it's like you know white
people will do [__] like this but then
they'll like cross the street when
walking on the same side with like a
black person but they'll stand on the
ledge of some [__] you know Cliff or
like Mount Everest it's like what are
you guys doing like what are you trying
to prove with all that wrestling gators
in the bayou like what the [__] is wrong
what I love all that why an Australian
[__] accent and then you brought up
the Bayou in [__] New Orleans but
like why really though this is what the
nature and the [__] with animals why
do you do that
I mean can't you do that with every
culture and race be like why do you do
that I suppose but I feel like white
people really like push the envelope in
terms of these extreme experiences in
nature and like I don't I don't know
because we we don't have any gangs why
people have gangs what are you talking
about but they're like there's so many
there are many white gangs no but like
okay name them
Jesse James Gang the Ku Klux Klan
uh I'm white people have gangs come on
you know like in certain areas like you
know they know we have groups
but our [__] is like mainstream okay I
remember a long time ago I got in this
[__] hilarious talk with Patrice can
you can you push that thing so it's not
rattling over there oh my God this whole
AC situation is is what we live in an
old house okay the [__]
heaters rattle a little bit
that we run the AC through using in here
um oh goodness you got a [__] Afghan
on I know and I'm so cold all right so I
got this hilarious argument one day like
Patrice when he used to just get sick of
white people would you know he just
would stop coming down to the club for a
little bit and then sometimes he would
call me up invent
about white people no he would vent at
me representing white people
so one time
I'm sitting at home just being white you
know
hanging out having a [__] peanut
butter and jelly sandwich phone [__]
rings I pick it up I'm like hello and he
just goes bill
he goes what what do white people do
so he didn't even say hello he goes what
what do you do
I'm like
I was like did you just get pulled over
by a cop like what where is this coming
from like what do you mean what what do
you mean what do we do like what he's
like what do you do like what are you
doing to the table yeah he's like black
people we do this we do that what do you
guys do mm-hmm
you're going that's hilarious like you
say yeah but the thing about it is how
did you answer him
I [__] answered him like I go what do
you mean what do we do you just don't
recognize our [__] is mainstream it's
it's like hiding in plain sight so you
don't see it so you don't think that you
don't think that there's any sort of
culture or anything like what do we do
um the all the actually look at
skateboarding okay that came from
surfing you know when the [__] waves
weren't there and it's you know
skateboarding and totally evolved into
what that is like Polynesian people were
doing stock car racing wait wait I'm not
gonna sit here and have you try to tell
me that white people didn't come up with
anything
the [__] Eskimos invent ketchup shut
up but I don't know skateboarding
Polynesians came up with skateboarding
no no but I saw the documentary it was
Dogtown and sea boys in a [__] empty
swimming pool in Santa Monica but I
thought skateboarding came from surfing
and this is the Polynesian people I
don't know I could be wrong do you
thought what didn't surfing come from
like indigenous people no no I'm not
talking about skateboarding I know but
the skateboarding came from surfing it
was sort of derived of that yes right so
I'm saying but then surfing come from so
you're saying white people don't get
credit for skateboard
I didn't say that I was just asking who
came up with a thing that inspired
skateboarding
I'm just wondering I
[Applause]
like that like literally then this
becomes the argument and a pound with
Patrice
all right stock car racing okay that
came out of moonshining what is that
basically the back during prohibition
when alcohol was [__] illegal right
what you would do is if you were [__]
bringing
illegal booze moonshine right you know
across state uh lines and all that type
of [__] you wanted a fast car but you
didn't want it to look fast so what you
did was it looked like a stock car like
a stock car you got from Detroit that
just looks like a Chevy that looks like
a Ford but underneath the [__] Hood
you soup the [__] thing up and you
were able to outrun the cops and the
cops didn't have [__] radios back
then so these guys that did this [__]
all right would talk [__] about my car
is faster than your car no it isn't blah
blah blah so they started racing and
that started stock car racing that's a
cultural [__] thing okay so then it's
on [__] TV like so I started listing
all of that [__] it was actually going
like he said I think one point he went
he said good answer is what he said and
I just I'm like [__] you I'm not asking
for your approval this whole [__]
conversation is Annoying It's not car
racing like something that's very
important to people like is it like a
big deal I don't know you're already
looking at this because I know
is somehow gonna go back to the [__]
blues like Beethoven heard the [__]
blues and the [__] Irish music and
all that like well if you actually the
nas would be like well it all came from
the pyramids and black people built
those how would you know that how would
you know that because you went to
amrite.com and you [__] read [__]
that said you guys did it like that is
the dumbest [__] like that whole [__]
credit thing is so [__] stupid
Egyptian Africa so that's African so
that's black people I know it isn't no
they're not aren't they they're African
yeah so that's my point yeah so so like
when you see when you see an Egyptian
guy right you think that guy looks like
you
I don't know I feel like some of them
are really all right so I'm French
German and Irish you're French so yeah I
have a little bit French but I'm mostly
German Irish let me finish oh so I'm a
European so me and Italians yeah we're
on the same [__] page so Ferrari yeah
that was us
pasty Freckle guys we did that [__] give
me a [__] break no you guys invented
like vodka and stuff like that
well no no Irish Russians sorry sorry I
don't know I don't know the history
I didn't want to get into this [__]
debate it's more of a like a yeah German
Irish whiskey
um
what's the other ones bourbon no is that
an American thing yeah yeah Scotch is
from Scotland bourbon's from Kentucky
yeah whiskey was but
egyptus was NASA's point is that was
that a true thing that yeah Africa is a
[__] continent yeah it is not a race
true it's a continent there you go so
like can Irish people take credit for
[__] that happens in Romania
because they're all European I feel like
there's a reason why this is different
but I don't know why so I'm not going to
answer that question but I feel like can
I [__] have that written on a t-shirt
like
I feel like an Egyptian person
really say I am African or would they
say I am Egyptian they would probably
say I am Egyptian yeah but I don't know
enough about all I know is that all the
[__] is in Africa so if you met anybody
over in Europe saying I'm European
French that's you I'm swish yeah swish
I'm Swiss
this is a this is actually this is like
a toxic this always becomes a toxic
conversation okay no I'm talking about
you and me I'm just saying because I
don't want to stir up everybody because
it's very easy yeah it can go off the
rails and it becomes this big [__]
race you're a [__] racist and all
this type of [__]
um resist the urge to read too much into
this people
anyways
I'm just so stockcars for white people
is what you were saying no no no I'm not
saying
wow you know what I hate about this
conversation what I hate about this
conversation I know it feels like that I
can't say anything I can't say I can't
say anything if I say anything I can't
come back that's true though if I say
anything then all of a sudden it's it's
this this and this there's a whole bunch
of [__] that I'm leaving off
because I'll then become I'll be called
a [__] elitist
okay what do we do we [__] pretend to
go the moon that's what we do
the space shuttle that's the [__] we you
just see it on TV
that's that's some [__] that we did I
mean that's that's kind of a cool no
it's amazing I know the astronauts
weren't rapping
they didn't have their space suits
hanging off their asses I know that the
kids didn't want but the kid's the
coolest but the kids still wanted to do
it get the [__] out of here
it's crazy
around with you I'm just I'm just
getting your goat because I see you've
wanted to LEAP out of your skin right
now uh can I say something right now I'm
saying but like I [__] hate when you
do that what my brother used to do that
do what you just say [__] to get me
going I'm being honest with you and I'm
saying what I'm feeling don't just be
sick you think I can't say some [__] to
get you going I know you can you do all
the time
I'm sorry I shouldn't have mocked stock
car racing or any of that stuff that
wasn't nice
yeah the thing you know what's [__]
yeah it's one of the greatest things
about stock car racing okay is what's
going the level of intellect in the pit
versus across the racetrack sitting in
the stands that's why I love going to
car races and is that why people think
that you're elitist or something no
because you got these guys like what the
[__] they have to do because it's so
regulated now just to try to squeeze it
and the [__] hundredth of a hundredth
of a second to try and win this [__]
race the the level of science
physics and all that [__] that's
involved that these guys the [__]
Egghead [__] that's going on in there
and then right across the track is just
[__] wait
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I don't know I I went to the
Indianapolis 500.
two years in a row I went to drag racing
do you know in between races they pull
the whole [__] engine out and rebuild
the whole goddamn thing in between races
there's a whole team of guys why
I don't know why because it matters that
much everything has to be brand new okay
like that cool song you guys made up
right brand new everything sorry
everything has to be [__] brand
because if it isn't
if it isn't a brand new [__] engine
the amount of money that could cost you
that Split Second it cost you was a
different like six figures wait a minute
wait a minute that's what they're doing
when they stop and all the guys run over
and they're like no no and drag and drag
racing they're they're changing the
engine I thought they were just like no
no no no no no no no no tires and like
wiping off the windshield
no I'm not talking I'm sorry I'm oiling
something maybe no no in that type of
racing
right
um
no no I'm talking about in Drag Racing
you know those long skinny cars with the
big [__] uh tires then they got the
parachute comes out in the back
the engine sits behind the driver they
finally figured out to do that after
years of them trying to see around it
why do they have a parachute though
don't they have brakes they do but it's
going 300 miles an hour oh so you need
all the help yeah and they don't have
flaps to put it down and you can't
reverse the engine like a plane I see
and they're Landing faster than a
[__] 747 but it doesn't weigh as much
but there's nothing that's all the
[__] physics okay and it's also
probably if they stop quicker they don't
have to [__] make as big of a track
and that saves the guy who owns the
track money all of this [__] all of this
[__] nerdy Egghead [__]
okay so this is what white people do
they get on a [__] they get on they
get on they get on a dirt bike
and they figure out how to go off a ramp
and flip in the air two times over and
they land in the foam and they figure
out how to do that and then they try to
land yeah they they we're we're bored
we're [__] bored white people need
gangs again like if you notice like
white people
I thought we were going to get into all
this in the 20s
when you have the gangs in New York was
that the 1800s I'm [__] good right
we would you know what it was
I know I could really try
yeah
yeah I could really trash white people
right now I could really say some mean
[__] about us
once the genocide in this country was
over and there was nothing left
we just got bored and we just started
[__] with animals there's really
something
about white people
um I mean I just feel like you're always
trying to like take over something or
like oppress somebody or like hurt
someone like why I would say this please
explain I don't think it's a white thing
it is an opportunity thing and most of
this most people before well if you
notice look at this business if you look
at most people in this business yeah you
see when they get a little something how
it affects them some people are fine
with it a lot of people when they get a
little bit of power
I'm talking just getting a [__] you
know enough money to have your little
personal assistant you know I asked for
decaf you know they start doing [__]
like that right and you talk and you're
talking about such a [__] basic level
when you get to the upper rational when
you're talking about like
you're going to start a [__] War
and you're actually going to profit off
of it
I mean and you go into those [__]
parties where everybody wears a mask and
you sort of walk away from your wife and
come back later and act like you didn't
[__] 40 women on a pile of gold like
human beings can't
have to be kept in check we can't handle
that level of power
so as [__] up as white people look if
you really read a little bit you know
not read I know you read all the time
but if you read about you know you go
over to Asia
you know there's some characters over
there that that will uh give white
people a run for their money
yeah no no
yeah well that's a very arrogant an
attitude why don't you read it first
okay yeah check out some of that stuff
you know go over there and uh bring up
Japan for anybody who doesn't live in
Japan about some of the [__] that they
did I really want to go to Japan though
I really want I know because you saw
Lost in Translation and you're not going
to read about it you're going to keep
thinking that white people the reason
why listen I mean I was I mean it's
definitely I used to do a bit my f
saying that white people are the Jordans
of evil
[Music]
like every group has the Hitlers we're I
don't know we're innately good at it
don't you want to go to Japan though
don't you want to see Tokyo I heard it's
something yeah no I like it I like it I
love the food and all that I'm not
listening I'm not singling out Japan
either like they're any [__] words to
anybody else but they got some
characters over there that have done
some things
well you know safely consulted them a
little bit between like the stock car
racing and everything else like
hopefully you guys will come back from
you know the brink because I feel like
your PR rep is is asleep at the wheel
what do you mean
listen one of the great things about
being White is you just don't give a
[__] what other people think about you
really clearly yeah I don't give a [__]
what you think
why would I give a [__]
you know what I mean
where's my question that I was supposed
to be asked I'm trying to find it right
now
yeah I went easy on you by the way with
skateboarding and stuff and stuck I went
easy okay I could I could have you know
I could have the other [__] you bring up
though then it's considered [__]
racist even if it happened
well we would have done that if we had
the opportunity
right isn't that what all the women say
I don't know I would have bench pressed
600 pounds if I was allowed to go to a
gym
oh my God how funny was it last night
we're not going to name names here okay
but after the fight when my buddy right
me and my buddy are hanging out I'm in
my late 40s he's in his early 50s ah
[__] you I'm not gonna say anybody's
name no no no no no no Nia Bill Nia bill
ah God you're such a [__] party
pooper that was just a generation gap
there yes it was hilarious
all right
all right I could do some advertising
here before you [__] all right oh my
God it's almost an hour over
after over no I'm saying the hour's
almost over I have like [__] verbal
dyslexia I can't even talk
so you're gonna walk out of Andrew you
just don't think white people have done
anything
not like culturally
is there anything that we get credit for
artistically that it's that Spike Lee or
some other grumpy guy with black frame
glasses isn't going to come along and
say well actually uh [__] uh
Pinetop Johnson [__] did that
originally
I feel like you guys probably were the
ones that started like using like a jug
like blowing on a jug as an instrument
hey like I feel like that was uh that
sounds like a white invention
not invention but just like blowing on
it somehow like we stopped with this
passive voice of drinking like all the
Moonshine remember you talked about
moonshine earlier like drinking
moonshine and then putting it down and
going whoo that was a lot of moonshine
and I was like oh that makes it
and then you came up with that
I'm really starting to wonder why you
married
well okay I'm Gonna Leave You to do your
advertising okay why don't you go read
up on some things
foreign
how smart was that I did not take the
bait come to Russia
all right I figure this is a travel one
maybe it could be into this okay
Irish sweaters we invented that
[Laughter]
[Music]
everybody's neck was cold until white
people came along and started started
knitting
um come to Russia
uh hey Billy commie Redford you guys
started barbecuing
you started that yeah and then we took
that from you yep we didn't take it from
you we just do influence you're still
allowed to do it
I don't understood that you took it from
us
what about all those Blues musicians
they never heard music before
they never heard
they didn't [__] they just slowed it
down what are you talking about
Beethoven played all those Blues notes
Beethoven yeah it was Beethoven an
American I'm just he was white oh okay
you're still oh you're still jumping
music all right
okay can we just move on to the
questions come on I like this this
shit's fun to me you didn't think that
was funny no
so really look there's really only seven
notes so everybody kind of played
everybody's showing shut up ukulele face
all right come to Russia
hey Billy commie red face I've been
listening to your podcast for for over a
year now and I was really excited to
hear about your Eastern European tour
next year but I'm pretty sure you don't
even think about going to Russia yeah I
do Moscow it's right near the Baltic
states I'm gonna try to go to Lithuania
and [__] uh those other two ones that
are there
Estonia that's two out of three that's
not bad for an American okay in uh
um I go to Moscow
sure Molly Crew went there you ready to
party Moscow yeah on MTV
yeah hair metal scene oh white people
definitely came up with that yeah
dressing up like a lady and singing rock
and roll
[Music]
Santa Claus came out with that I thought
Santa Claus was like a no not like I
don't know it's Santa Claus black no
it's from another country though it's
not I was gonna say that'd be the
courteous name ever for a black guy all
right hey Billy come here at first blah
blah blah I'm pretty sure you never
think about Russia I know it's very
unlikely for an English-speaking
Community to visit us but Dylan Moran
and Eddie Izzard did it a couple Yeah
Eddie Izzard probably did it in Russian
you guys like Albert Einstein telling
jokes did it a couple years ago and it
turned out great well if you decide to
come here after all you should not you
should bring Nia sorry I just my eyes
went to Nia I saw the end you should
bring Nia okay and visit Saint
Petersburg not only because that's the
second largest city in Russia and I
lived there but because of the beautiful
architecture lots of museums I hate
museums
hate museums [__] going there looking
at plates and [__] this is a spoon
somebody using the 1500s oh yeah
you can see the beginning of the
microwave in this structure and all that
crap I think she'd love it here I also
hope uh you'll at least consider St Pete
as it's not far away from Scandinavia
and everything here has become way
cheaper for tourists because of our weak
currency now he's in St Petersburg then
that used to belong to Finland and they
beat Russia in World War II but they
were down with Hitler and then they had
to give up that part
or is that something else I have no idea
that's right yeah why would you but if
we go there and [__] Riot is playing
somewhere I'd love to check them out
why would you do that why would I do
what go see [__] right in Brooklyn put
some [__] nerdy white kid that wants
me naked on TV for six months that's
what you do you don't see it in Russia
where you get arrested you're showing
you clams
I can't show you clam in Russia on the
on the unrelated note I subscribed to
Netflix just to watch your show last
December
uh because you just couldn't stop
bitching about the pirating like how he
turns it around on me like I'm the
[__] and Netflix is not even
available in Russia so I have to use the
VPN and [__] oh poor [__] baby uh you
go see how much we love you here please
come to our beautiful and totally not
hostile country and see it for yourself
that's not what a cab driver told me
when I was over there in Europe so you
got to be careful in Moscow after dark
but then again you got to be careful
here uh please come to our beautiful
totally know always yeah what the [__] I
would love to see you St Petersburg I
think that would be really cool you know
be funny if it's a totally [__] up
City and this guy hates me and he just
lures me over there
beats me over the head with my mixer
all right female coach hey Billy butt
kiss
uh thoughts on the Cardinals hiring a
female coach I hear she can take a hit
I think she's got what it takes or is it
a publicity stunt what does that mean
take a hit
I think it's football I had no idea that
they did it
you didn't read about this I I no I
tapped out on the news during during
Hillary Clinton Bruce Jenner and
somewhere around there I just I just
I've been too busy to watch anything on
the news I heard that there was a woman
that was hired to be an NFL coach but I
don't you know I don't follow football
so
um that seems like a very big deal
why because they've never had a female
coach before
yes but how is that like how is that
going to uh
affect wins and losses
it probably I probably won't matter what
gender you are you'd like to be a girl I
think yeah yeah but it's it's still like
um it's never been done before so it's
historical right yes it is it is a story
we have a lot to we have yet to learn
any lessons if any just yet but it's a
big deal that it's happening it's a
publicity stuff
it's not a publicity so I'm not saying
she's not qualified but this is what the
NFL is a corporation and every quarter
they have to have a
a show a game
that's just how a corporation works and
they're trying to make more money so
they have reached every possible [__]
football fan
all right they did that years ago so
then they started bringing in people
like Britney Spears to sing
during the Super Bowl just trying to get
people hooked on it and then they wear
pink for a whole [__] month now
they're getting in with trying to get in
with the ladies they're trying to get
more it's just it's I think it's a
business move that's going to be
disguised as uh forward thinking I'm not
saying she's bad and not qualified or
anything but I just think that that's
why they're going to do that
um
I don't give a [__] I don't have to I
don't give a [__] if she's good and they
win but I think it's a good move if uh
she stinks
uh unfortunately uh all the other women
behind her will be judged so I imagine
she has a lot of pressure
it's just weird when you go into the
locker room you know what I mean
everybody's standing there with their
dicks out and [__] you know what I mean
now they got to cover up
it's weird
uh you'd rather they just be able to
stand around with their dicks out and
not have to worry about covering up
well I mean I don't think like that does
the male coach walk into the females
locker room is just sitting there taking
off their sports bras probably not they
go look we gotta get out there in the
second half and shave your clamp slowly
get down
probably not
definitely not put them afterwards
definitely not not in the last so she
probably does the same thing definitely
not she's not in there like talking to
them like there's no way no but you can
but then that then that hurts her as a
coach that [__] can't go in there when
they're standing there with their dicks
out because she's gonna hurt her as a
coach because they go in and they
discuss strategy during halftime you go
into the locker room to talk about that
are they naked during halftime no but
after the game you talk about the next
week and that type of [__] but if
somebody got hurt it's a locker room
somebody's got their dick out it just
happened somebody's got to take a [__]
at halftime it [__] happened I guess
that's what I was wondering do you have
to be naked just because you're in the
locker room yeah and this is what's
gonna happen
this is what's going to be all the
adjustment
they're just going to keep adjusting it
okay yeah and then a guy can't have his
dick out in a [__] men's locker room
oh the Injustice of it you see what I'm
saying though you guys just keep
encroaching
encroaching encroaching encroaching and
then we always have to adjust to you you
guys do not adjust to us well if you're
walking into a men's locker room there's
going to be a dick out you're gonna have
to either [__] deal with it okay or
you have somebody go in there and take
some notes I'm sure she is prepared to
deal with any dicks that are out I'm
sure I'm sure it'll be fine
you guys are obsessed with us well yeah
yeah okay you're obsessed with keeping
your dick out in the locker room so what
does that say about you no I'm sure you
guys are obsessed with us yeah we're
totally obsessed with you yes
why can't you guys just start your own
[__] and [__] go do that well it's
not a stock car company why why do you
guys always have to come it's a men's
football league there was a woman's
football league I wouldn't give a [__] I
gotta get in there stand next to some
clams and discuss strategy I'd let you
have your [__] deal
absence makes the heart grow fonder and
the most loving way ever [__] off
can you [__] off for three hours on a
Sunday can we just have a minute
Jesus Christ the [__] that's set in a
locker room then they're gonna get
offended they I love it I love that the
NFL's doing this I guarantee there's
going to be some something [__] up
happens there's going to be a lawsuit
then that happened years ago
it happened in Boston right the [__]
the woman went in there and these guys
acted like [__] immature idiots and
then there was a lawsuit and then she
had to go to New York it was a funny guy
to sell the team it was nuts
I don't know I don't know I'm talking
about dicks being out in locker rooms
nothing good very bad can happen about
that yeah Jesus Christ needed I'm
uncomfortable in a [__] locker room I
go to the goddamn gym you [__] go in
there okay
you're staring at your eyelids
but eventually you're gonna walk by
somebody taller than you
[Music]
it's gonna be hanging down
you're in a men's locker room you're
gonna see a dick it just happened if I
was gonna say men don't like talk to
each other like naked in the locker room
so the other day I went to dude
well this is not there's also a
generational thing as far as being
comfortable being naked around another
man in a locker oh like the old guys
don't care they don't give a [__] yeah
they do they grew up in The Little
Rascals era they they like the parents
bedroom and then all the kids slept in
the same [__] bed with a dog and like
a [__] Wolverine right
then you had my generation I was one of
the last Generations that in gym class
the guys gym class you went in and when
you showered it was just this communal
[__] shower and you went in there
like a bunch of cattle
[__] you
no stalls or anything everyone's just
went in there there's a bunch of like
shower heads all around yeah but no
stalls that started in sixth grade and I
remember I've never been in the first
week
the first week of gym class only like
six kids had the [__] balls no pun
intended to take the shower and they
went in the shower and it was wide open
like all the lockers were all the way
around it the school I went to so you
could like they walked in that dude and
me and like there was like six other
guys we were laughing like hysterically
these are kids I knew all the way
through grade school and they came
walking by butt ass naked and that's the
thing about a naked guy it's either the
funniest thing ever or absolutely
terrifying to spending time
on the situation and it was [__]
hilarious but after like two three weeks
it was normal and no one gave a [__]
and we were part of the last like
generation we thought it was like when
we I mean we heard like the women's
gym they they had their own little
private showers
which was weird to me you'd think the
guys would be [__] more weirded out
we were actually more advanced than you
guys more mature we could all shower
together
I don't know if that's what that really
means what does it means that you know
you're all animals I'll just throw you
in there and hose it down I know that's
really what it was yeah you [__]
animals yeah so anyway so there's
there's different levels of uh like
generational
you know what I mean
that guys will just like old guys don't
give a [__]
they don't give a [__] and then there's
the weird guy
who also doesn't give a [__] you don't
know what he's doing that guy you come
walking in right
did Jim I go to like you can see like
you come walking in the lockers are to
the right and then straight ahead is
like the sink area
with the mirror and [__] and like you
know I walked in there one time and
there was a guy standing there
completely naked except flip-flops
shaving
and I just I walked in I just and I just
went yes really you can't [__] just
throw a towel on anyways
I'm just saying
dicks be out in the locker room all
right Big Green Egg hey Bill
congratulations on the new Big Green Egg
actually he's had it for a couple years
uh I'm not by any means an expert but
I've been experimenting since December
with mine based on your description we
have about the same setup egg the guru
with two probes and a fan rib rack Etc I
also have a pan that I keep water in yep
I've seen that that you put on the plate
Setter right
uh and put it in there while I'm smoking
all right so he says I put it on top of
the smoking plate yes just like I've
seen in the YouTube videos he goes I'm
not sure how much of a difference it
makes but it seems to keep the inside of
the Big Green Egg pretty human and it
catches a lot of the drippings a few
pointers keep the charcoals
at the line all right that's the fill up
line
I think that's what they said
um soak the chips but don't soak the
chunks
um you can soak the chunks but they
smoke just fine without soaking
yeah it's Hickory it Just Smokes right
it's easy to get the Big Green Egg
hotter but really hard to get the
temperature lower if you overshoot the
temperature is all about air flow the
top vent on a slow cook 225 ish is
cracked to about a quarter inch this is
what I've seen on YouTube when you clean
out the ash make sure you have it
cleaned you've cleared all the holes on
the bottom of the grill they can usually
clog up and the Big Green Egg won't
perform like it usually does this is if
you're going to smoke something for ribs
I've had luck with the yellow mustard
spice rub combo dude you watch the same
[__] thing this is the video you
showed me with the Mustang yeah prep the
ribs the night before make sure you
remove the membrane from the ribs before
you rub it down and make sure the ribs
out of the fridge and let them get to
room temperature before you slap them on
the smoker usually takes about eight
hours or so for three racks I can't wait
to try this but I just set the
temperature to 225 and let them go until
the ribs get to 190. I wrap them in foil
and let them rest about 20 minutes
uh dude I I can't I cannot [__] wait
to do that I'm gonna get good at that
[__]
I'm gonna try ribs in a pork shoulder
this month hopefully oh Cleo
um all right let's get through this
because this thing's gonna take forever
for me to upload
all right uh yeah you want to go yeah
all right good to see you that was that
was a fun one
I love The Jug thing that was The Jug
thing was good I feel pretty strongly
about that joke
you got so passive aggressive you're
like so like hey
[__] with that Ronda Rousey Fest when
she talks about a
you know she talks about I always say
everybody's name am I say a name right
Ronda Rousey
yeah all right she [__] gets that
[__]
dead look on her face like yeah
destruction is about to happen all right
eating help
oh by the way most of those fights kind
of stunk on that one except for that one
where the guys ended just doing the
Rock'em sock'em bleeding all over each
other that was just my wife [__]
freaks out
when that [__] happens not in like
freaking out like oh my God gross she
loves it
standing up screaming at the TV grounded
pound grounded pound yes I [__] love
it
lunatic all right eating help dear Bill
bills and Roses hello from Wisconsin
ah the badges I'm 22 year old factory
worker and guitarist
Jesus Christ
I used to work in a [__] warehouse
and I played drums with a bunch of
musicians
how do you guys always end up in the
[__] Factory oh the Factory's not a
warehouse
bill just read the goddamn question all
right I've been a fan of yours for five
to six years and want to first thank you
for everything you've put on all right
all right nothing
looking forward to F is for family got
to get that plug in there okay uh the
reason I'm writing to you is
I for my entire 22 years of existence
have had a hard have had a hard gut
that I never ever been able to shake off
earning myself the nickname teapot at an
early age for my short and stout
appearance oh God that's hilarious
I'm a Little Teapot shorted style then
they started calling you teapot oh and
you started have fantasies of murdering
all of them anyways I wouldn't say I'm
obese but I'm certainly starting to lose
the Battle of the Bulge while I get a
bit of exercise from work and hit the
gym once in a while my diet is complete
[__] the thing is I was raised on
takeout fast food and fried fats dude
the fact that you're not a big teapot
is pretty amazing there so that's
already a victory he says I literally
don't know how or what to eat or where
to start for that matter
all right well I would go on the
internet and I would start looking up
nutrition all right shocker that this
Wisconsin native is a shitty eater most
uh where most of the populations looks
like they could play o-line for Mr
Rogers and the Packers
uh could you please give a few days
worth of meals to eat to lose pounds I
figured I figured now is the time to get
in shape absolutely and attract a cutie
so I can start to build my Empire
uh all right P.S Tom Brady is innocent
and anyone who thinks otherwise is just
upset because they have to watch their
team eat [__] every Sunday unlike our
Powerhouse Dynasty teams best luck best
of luck to braiding the Patriots
organization see that see that what
happens when you give respect to the
Packers the true New York Yankees
of the [__] NFL because they want all
they won in every [__] era other than
the 20 years after uh
Lombardi and Bart Starr
you know they went to Lynn Dickey the
magic man and then they got Brett Favre
and then it's been all good
they used to be they [__] won
championships in the 1930s all the way
I've already read off all their [__]
Champion NFL championships Super Bowl
championships whatever Championship
existed whatever era they [__] wanted
they won more than anybody else all
right here we go
all right um well all right this is what
I every day what I've been doing is I
have oatmeal and a banana I don't put
anything in the oatmeal no milk no sugar
no honey none of that [__] [__] I
have that and then for a snack between
that and lunch I have an apple and then
for lunch I have a sandwich with a side
salad sometimes I just have the meat and
no bread
um and that's if I'm I'm
you know I weigh myself every day and I
try to lose two to three pounds and if I
feel like I'm off course I won't have
the [__] bread
um
and then I don't know between like
[__] uh
lunch and dinner I don't know what I
have
I usually try to eat something healthy
if the worst thing I'll do is maybe
cereal or I'll scramble a couple of eggs
and then for dinner I either go totally
veggie or I do the protein the size of a
hand my hand my palm of my hand I should
say and a side salad none of this [__]
is groundbreaking you can find all of
that
online and I try to stop eating like
around you know six-ish around six
o'clock after that I just drink water
the whole night and if I'm hungry I have
pre-cut celery sticks in the
refrigerator that I will either just eat
those or if I'm really feeling kind more
hungry than that I will have like a half
a spoon or a spoonful of peanut butter
and you [__] do that and you add
cardio the Fat's got nowhere to go at
least for me and it's just been falling
off my body although I'm still
disgusting man I can still sit here and
just grab a nice [__] handful but
whatever man I've lost 10.2 pounds 10
point I'm shaving down the ham here
people
all right Boston hates the Olympics this
is the last one uh hey there Billy Jim
rat I read Boston won the bid to host
the 2024 Olympic games but the city
couldn't get the citizens behind it
apparently Boston residents don't want
the games to be held there I thought
that was weird because Boston always
seems very proud of America to me I
figured they'd be stoked about hosting
the games they root for a team called
the Patriots but have little or no
interest in watching America's Finest
athletes compete I would like to hear
your take on this and I'd also like to
know what position you take on the
matter if you were living back East
thanks and go [__] yourself yeah what
kind of [__] [__] wants the Olympics
in that town
you don't want the Olympics in your town
you want your the Olympics in the city
that's close to you so you can drive to
it if you want to go see it like I
wouldn't want it in Boston I put it in
Hartford
I don't deal with that [__] traffic
the traffic's already [__] up as it is
they don't need a bunch of people coming
over here it's not is it the Winter
Olympics at least Olympic hockey would
be the [__] but nobody gives a [__]
about track
the high jump and all of that [__] I
don't want to see that I like the Winter
Olympics and even then [__] put it in
New Hampshire there's too much traffic
in Boston they got like 40 highways and
they all [__] merge right at the TD
Bank North Garden and there's no way to
go they stuck it all underground because
it's so [__] annoying to look at and
they put a park over the top of the off
top of the thing and they try to act
like it isn't happening it's a complete
[__] [__] show
yeah it's a [__] show when there isn't
the Olympics
all right we don't we don't need that
[__] we don't need that [__] all right
[__] that you want the Olympics you've
taken we'll come and visit you
you know what I mean that's like that
old analogy I said my brother taught me
about having a boat he's like you don't
have a boat you want to have a friend
who has a boat then you just show up
with the 12 pack and you're a hero and
then you [__] leave at the end of the
day and he's got to deal with the
Barnacles and docking the [__] thing
that's the same thing with the Olympics
you don't want the Olympics in your city
the only people who want the Olympics in
the city are the people that make money
off of building the tents and the [__]
that the people at the tents the [__]
State those people want it there nobody
else wants it [__] there and by the
way they're not the finest [__]
athletes okay the finest [__]
athletes get paid
you know what I mean
they're professional at these are
amateurs
it's a [__] it's Sports open mic
who the [__] wants to watch that and
have it tie up traffic all right
everybody that's how I feel on that [__]
um
I hope you enjoyed that debate that fun
debate I just had with Nia
um
what was I gonna say what else do I get
I keep saying it's fun so I just please
don't if you're gonna be [__] ugly
about it just write to somebody else's
podcast just try to have a good sense of
humor about the [__] okay we've all
contributed in our own little way
culturally racially humanly all of that
all right don't be [__] morons all
right so anyways that's a podcast for
this [__] week
um I'll I'll check in on you on Thursday
that's the podcast thank you so much for
listening go [__] yourselves I'll talk
to you on Thursday